hey what's up guys um could be HD here
and welcome back to another video
another Tesla video but probably not the
Tesla video that we ever wanted to make
but here we are so a couple days ago on
Friday afternoon on the way from a
top-secret location or shooting a video
to come here to the studio actually got
hit by a truck so well crash didn't go
too well so first of all I am totally
fine I was not even scratched or bumped
not injured at all so that's been fine
but here's what happened so you might
have heard about all the weather in the
East Coast of the past couple of days
have been pretty weird we got some snow
dumped on us and it all melted real
quick this happened in the middle of
that but it actually had nothing to do
with the weather so on the highway it's
a three lane highway I was in the far
right lane
there was a truck in the middle lane I
wasn't passing it I was actually pretty
much matching at speed we're in traffic
so everyone's going 35 miles an hour and
I must have blend in his blind spot long
enough that when he decided for whatever
reason he was gonna merge into the right
lane he just did it and I was there so I
guess from his perspective he was just
looking at an empty lane he merges and
suddenly he's plowing a car it was kind
of weirdly surreal just because I've
seen accidents happen especially with a
lot of truckers but a lot of accidents
are usually just kind of like an impact
and then they're over pretty quick this
one was like an impact and then I felt
it happened and then I realized this is
I'm this is a crash of some kind but
then it just kept going and scraping and
going and going just because his car
started his truck started at the back
bumper on my rear left wheel and he had
so much momentum that's an 80,000 pound
truck that it just kept scraping and
going forward forward along the side of
my car until it clipped the front and
mirror from inside the car it was
actually pretty minor I barely like I
felt like it was just basically a hand
pushing my car sideways out of the road
it was kind of weird but just the fact
that I never saw it coming because he
came from almost behind me and tried to
speed up to merge into my lane that's
why it was so blind so anyway that all
happens I pull over he pulls over and
actually got out the car and just took
those
that I ended up eventually posting on
Twitter that you've probably seen by now
you know it's funny actually somebody on
reddit from I guess a dashcam passing by
got a video of me right after I'd taken
those photos so the internet stays stays
ready for this type of stuff they stay
ready but basically yeah we obviously
call the police because it's an accident
the truck driver he gets out he's pretty
apologetic he says look I sorry I didn't
see you I don't think he really had
anything else to say there so you know
you call the insurance you call a
roadside that's that's taken care of
the only other interesting variable is
obviously we each have our own insurance
company and I'm pretty sure we'll be in
agreement when the police report
eventually gets filed that it was the
trucks fault because he merged into a
lane
I wasn't passing on the right he just
happened to not see me it happens it's
fine but that was the one little
variable but now we're an interesting
place because this is this is actually
one of the biggest complaints and one of
the areas where Tesla owners have the
most negative to say about the company
Tesla repairs are one thing that I've
heard from couple friends who owned
Tesla's and of course in forums and on
reddit and things like that they take a
long time not necessarily because the
repair action itself takes a long time
but because it takes Tesla a really long
time to get out parts that need to be
sent to start the repairs now that is of
course assuming that this can be
repaired I know I did ask on Twitter
does this I mean it looks pretty bad but
do you think you know replace the doors
replace the rear 3/4 you think this is
not totaled and a lot of people actually
seem to think as long as the frame is
bent as long as the battery and motors
aren't damaged in any way should be okay
now this morning I got a phone call and
it was from the auto body shop and Tesla
hasn't brought the car to them yet
but they kind of they sent the pictures
and a sort of a description of it to
them and they believe that it can be
repaired so that's good news
so the challenge now is we have to wait
for the police report which will be
filed in the next 10 days just because
State Police take longer because it was
on a highway and it will hopefully find
that the truck driver was at fault don't
know how it could be any other way but
that's the case then his insurance
can come get involved and help pay for
it and my insurance will have to there's
a whole bunch of insurance logistics but
at the end of the day my biggest
question is how does Tesla handle it I
think one could argue that my
relationship with Tesla as people have
pointed out could be seen as
preferential right I've I've had a
pretty good relationship with my service
center every time I go in there we know
each other guys we talk about camera
stuff we talked about the interview I
did with Elan things like that we're all
pretty cool there I could see how they
would say that that's preferential
treatment but this is a new scenario
with a body shop that I've never had any
contact with a new relationship with a
new company insurance companies that's
all messy but the question is will this
be a big pain point to owning a Tesla
the question of do you total the car or
do you repair it ultimately comes down
to the cost of repair Tesla's our higher
end vehicles they cost more if the cost
of repair of a vehicle is too high
relative to the cost of the car then the
insurance company will just decide
that's a total just pay for the value of
the car get a new one
but with a high value car like the Tesla
and a high cost of repair it actually
doesn't match up and you probably can
still spend more money on fixing it so
on one hand I'm glad that it's not
totaled and that Apollo hopefully when
they see it in person it'll agree with
what they found in the photos and
they'll find that it can be fixed but on
the other hand this might take a while
I'm just gonna have to keep Oh bring
everywhere until we figure this whole
thing out so that's that's basically it
that's the outline that's where we're at
right now I'll keep you guys updated on
Twitter if I you know when I get more
updates and we start to go through this
process but that's my question have any
you guys had similar experiences with an
auto body shop maybe even with Tesla
having to wait a long time for parts
before you actually get in and the
repair only takes a couple days let me
know what you guys think so yeah not not
the Tesla video that I thought I'd be
making today or ever but we'll see how
this goes it's the beginning of a
process and I'll let you know fingers
crossed
all right that's pretty much it thanks
for watching don't you guys the next one
pace